Here's a specific example I want to show you so
you can see how other audience members might view the graphic.
You don't want to create a visualization that confuses or
alienates your readers.
And that's why you want to avoid using standard red and green colors.
They're often hard for those who are color blind to interpret.
The difference between these red bars and this green text may seem obvious to
you, however, not everyone will see it this way.
Some viewers in your audience will see this.
Here there is little to no difference between the red bars that we
say before and the green text.
And now I want to make a subtle distinction, here.
I'm not saying that you should never use red or
green hues, because they can be used in visualizations.
This graphic was re-released after a color correction from
the Wall Street Journal.
It's a heat map that shows historic trends for
unemployment in the United States.
The rose represent the months of the year and
the columns represent one year of time.
The key here is that hues of red and green were used in such a way
that people even with color blindness could still make out the differences.
Now this is a pretty incredible interactive graphic.
And it also makes use of a diverging color scale.
But, if you want to see something even more incredible, I highly recommend that
you check out the remake of this visualization in the instructor notes.
Alberto Cairo, a professor at the University of Miami, redesigned this graphic,
and you can also find it in his book, The Functional Art.